GOPAL ASHOK: Hello.
My name is Gopal Ashok.
I'm the Product Manager
for Cloud Memorystore.
Today we're going to
talk about optimally
deploying an application
cache with Memorystore.
So let's begin.
So there are a few areas
that I want to cover today.
So I'll start with talking
a little bit about why
it is important to
have an in-memory store
in your application
architecture,
and what benefits it provides.
From there, we'll
talk a little bit
about Redis, and why Redis
is one of the most popular
in Memorystores to date.
And from there, we will
dive into Memorystore.
Start with the overview
of the product, what
are some other key features
and key capabilities
that we provide.
But more importantly,
the key thing
that I would like you to take
away from this presentation
is, what are some of
the best practices
that you should be using when
you are deploying Memorystore
for your application use cases?
So I think we all
know Memorystores
are a critical part of modern
application architecture.
But let's take a close look
at why that is the case.
Without storing data--
or storing and processing
data and memory, it
is impossible to get
the speed that is required
by applications today.
And we all know that the
speed of the applications
and the response time
of the application
essentially determines user
retention, which essentially
means it translates to how
well your business will do.
So having a Memorystore
that can deliver
the speed that is required
by modern applications
is super-critical.
The other aspect of
it is that speed also,
in a way, or lack of
speed also, in a way,
translates to availability.
If the website is
super-slow, that essentially
means a website is unavailable.
So again, a Memorystore
allows you not only just
to have the speed that is
needed by the application,
but it's also a
critical component
to deliver on the
availability that
is required by the application.
And the other key aspect where
a Memorystore comes into play,
along with speed and
available, is cost.
So there are a lot
of use cases where
you can benefit from having
a Memorystore in front
of your database,
or back-end store,
for example, that will allow you
to reduce the total cost when
it comes to data access.
So by creating a lot more
data from the Memorystore,
you can actually provision,
or downsize, or rightsize
your back-end
store provisioning,
which can help you manage
the overall cost for the data
access.
So as you can see, a Memorystore
is a super-critical component
which allows you to do enable
your application to scale,
and provide the speed
and the responsiveness
that the application needs.
It allows you to have
better availability,
and also, it helps
you manage the cost.
So if you take an example,
which is a very common example
of user sessions, or
using-- or a session store,
typically, what happens
in these scenarios
is that you start off with
using a back-end database
as your session store.
And for example, let's
say your application
is a ticketing application.
And if you are using a back-end
store for-- a back-end database
as your session store,
it'll scale well
for a certain amount of time.
But once your
application takes off
and you get thousands--
or hundreds of thousands
of concurrent
connections, you will
notice that your back-end
store or back-end database,
for example, post-gres, is
not actually going to scale.
And this is where having a
Memorystore in the architecture
really, really helps.
So you can store your
sessions in the Memorystore,
and basically,
because the processing
time and the processing
is done in-memory,
and the processing happens
within milliseconds,
your overall latency
for the application
can come down from
hundreds of milliseconds
in the 90th percentile,
to maybe tens
of milliseconds towards
the 90th percentile.
So having a Memorystore
for your-- or for scaling
your application
architectures is
super, super important today.
So let's take a look at what
are some of the popular choices
when it comes to a Memorystore.
I think when you look
at the usage, it is--
there's no argument that Redis
is the most popular store
today.
You can argue most
applications, regardless
of industry or vertical, use
or can benefit from Redis.
And the popularity is
reflected in dB Engines,
which is a popular website
for rating databases.
And also in this Stack
Overflow survey, where
users, developers, and admin--
dev ops folks rated Redis
as the most-loved database.
So it's super-clear
that Redis is
a very, very popular database,
or Memorystore, that is
used across applications today.
Why is Redis so popular?
Redis is an extremely
fancy Memorystore
that provides
sub-millisecond processing.
But more importantly, it
provides rich data structures
that allow application
developers to do
fast computations of
applications logic
on the service side.
On top of that, Redis
also provides capabilities
like Pub/Sub and
streaming, which
allows app developers to build
queuing applications, streaming
applications, and that
too at a very high scale.
Apart from that, Redis also
provides high availability
and scaling features
that allows Redis
to be used across a wide variety
of use cases at varying scale.
So altogether, Redis has
become the number 1 choice
for in-memory stores for
building modern application
architecture.
So if you're migrating to GCP
or building your applications
on GCP, Cloud
Memorystore provides you
a fully-managed Redis and
Memcached service on GCP.
So if you are either migrating
your application from on-prem,
or if you are migrating
an application
from a different cloud, or if
you are managing your own Redis
on GCE, you now have
a fully-managed Redis
and Memcached service that you
can use to deploy your Redis
and Memcached instances.
I think that the key thing
about having Memorystore
as a fully-managed service
is that it takes away
the burden of managing the
caching infrastructure.
So let's take a look at
some of the key features
and capabilities of Memorystore.
At the highest level,
as I mentioned,
Memorystore provides
a fully-managed Redis
and Memcached service.
The service is built on
opensource Redis and Memcached,
which means you can easily lift
and shift your applications
with very minimum effort.
The other thing
that we enable is
that maintaining a
caching infrastructure
is not easy, especially
when you have
to maintain a highly-available
caching infrastructure.
So if you were to
do it yourself,
then you have to
maintain a proxy layer.
You have to manage all the VMs.
You have to make sure that
you cache the VMs, et cetera.
And with Memorystore, we
take care of all that for you
without our own health checks,
automatic fadeover monitoring,
et cetera.
And on top of that, you get
the Google-grade security,
where we ensure that the
infrastructure is deployed
in a very secure environment,
where we use private IPs,
and you have restricted
access to specific networks,
et cetera.
So overall, with
Memorystore, you
get a fully-managed service
that is highly-available
and also highly-secure.
And with that, you
don't really have
to spend time managing
your Redis and Memcached
infrastructure.
You can just focus on
building your applications.
So let's take a closer look
at some of the capabilities
that we provide for
Memorystore for Redis.
So Memorystore for Redis comes
in two flavors, a basic tier
and a standard tier.
And the basic tier is a
standalone instance of Redis.
And standard tier is a
highly-available instance
of Redis, with a
primary and a replica.
We support up to 300
gigabytes in data set size.
But the key thing that
I want you to note here
is that both the tiers are
essentially single-primary.
So that means we don't support
scale-out architecture yet.
So the QPS that
Memorystore supports
is limited to what a
single primary can support.
So when you architect
your application,
that is something that
you should keep in mind.
And I'll talk more about that
in the Best Practices section.
Apart from that, we
provide a backup.
So if you're using Memorystore
as a critical or primary store,
you can take backups
of your data.
So in case of
catastrophic failure,
you can restore from the backup.
And we support
multiple versions,
including Redis version 5.0.
We've also been working
on some new features
over the last few months.
So we have shipped
Redis version 5.0.
But one of the other key
features that we have shipped
is support for shared VPC.
So if you are deploying
applications and service
projects, and you want to deploy
Memorystore using a shared VPC
network, you can do that today.
So before this
feature was enabled,
you were not able to deploy
Memorystore instances
in service projects.
You had to deploy
it in post-project.
But now you will
be able to do that.
One thing to note here is that
this feature today is only
available as part of G Cloud.
We are working on the UI.
But if you look into
the documentation,
you will see the
steps that you'll
have to go through to enable
shared VPC for Memorystore.
And lastly, we
also enable support
for VPC Service Controls.
So if you're using
VPC Service Controls,
Memorystore works very
seamlessly with it.
We are also excited to
announce that we have--
we are providing
support for Memcached
as part of Memorystore.
So what we have
heard from customers
is that there are a lot
of Memcached deployments
out there for
legacy applications.
And even for some
new applications,
customers would like
to use Memcached.
And with the support
for Memcached today,
now you have a fully-management
Memcached instance that
is available with Memorystore.
The Memcached instance is
a scale-out architecture,
so we support up to 20 nodes.
You can scale from
1 to 20 nodes,
and you can have
individual shots.
Up to 256 gigs with 32 VCPUs.
So we brought a
lot of flexibility,
in terms of shaping your
cluster for the different types
of application workloads that
you may have for Memcached.
One of the other
key things that we
provide as part of the service
is the Discovery Endpoint,
which allows you to
basically discover
all the nodes in the
cluster from an application
perspective.
So that way, when you're scaling
your clusters in and out,
you always know what
your topology looks like,
and you don't have to basically
change your app configurations
when you scale your
clusters up and down.
So that's a very
convenient service
that allows you to
minimize the amount of work
that you need to do whenever
you do scaling of a Memcached
cluster.
So we are super-excited about
enabling Memcached for you.
We are currently in beta, and
we will be going GA pretty soon.
OK, so we touched
upon a few things.
We touched upon why
caching is important.
We touched upon some of the
benefits of using Redis.
And we talked about Memorystore.
But the key thing that
I want to talk about
for the remaining time that
we have in this presentation
is about the use
cases and patterns,
and based on that,
what is the best
practices that you
should follow when
you are deploying Memorystore?
So let's take a look at
the use cases and patterns.
So the way we look
at use cases is
when it comes to
Redis, especially,
Redis supports a wide
variety of use cases.
So from a simple web content
cache or a database cache,
to a distributed log,
recommendation engines,
threat detection, fraud
detection, whatnot.
So there are a wide
variety of use cases
that Redis is used for.
But the key thing
to understand is
that each of these use cases
maps to four different,
what I call, "caching patterns."
And the caching
patterns essentially
determine the behavior
that is expected
from that caching layer for
that particular use case.
So we see four different use--
caching patterns.
The Ephemeral Cache, the
Capacity Cache, the Transient
Store, and the Primary Store.
And I'll talk more about
the characteristics
of these patterns
in the next slide.
But along with the
patterns, there
is also the Workload Pattern,
which essentially determines
the scale, in terms of
data set size, and the QPS;
the read-write ratio
for the application when
it comes to accessing the cache;
and also the payload size.
So the combination of
the workload patterns,
along with the caching
patterns, determines
what type of deployment
you should be doing
for your particular use case.
So let's take a look at the
different caching patterns
and what that really means.
So Ephemeral Cache,
you can think of it
as a very simple cache.
If the cache goes away, you
can re-hydrate the cache
from a back-end store.
There's no real impact
to the application,
except for maybe
a slow perform--
a small performance
depredation that is not
significant from an
application perspective.
And for these kind
of use cases, it
may be enough to just deploy
a memcache or the basic tier
of Redis, which is
actually very, very cheap.
But when it comes to the
Transient Store use case,
it becomes a little
bit more interesting.
So you have a use case
like session store
where you have-- you
want to store the keys
for a certain amount of time.
But you want the keys to be
available for that period
of time, because
if you lose a key,
then the user
experience suffers.
Again, it is not catastrophic.
But again, you
don't-- but again,
the user experience
can get impacted,
which can also translate to
bad customer satisfaction,
and customers probably
leaving your service.
So you want to
make sure that when
you have use cases
like session store,
your keys are highly-available.
The primary store becomes an
even more interesting use case
where it is the primary
store that is backing your--
for example, your
front-end website.
And that data doesn't
exist anywhere else.
The data is typically
processed by offline processing
during the day, and it is
ingested into a Redis instance.
And that essentially
accesses the primary store
for the applications using it.
So it's super-important for that
layer to be highly-available.
And for that
particular use case,
it is also important to
ensure that the instance is
very highly-available.
But you also want to ensure
that the data is backed up,
in case there is a
catastrophic failure,
so that you can recover
using the backup when
the failure happens.
And lastly, Capacity
Cache is interesting
from the perspective of how
customers deploy the cache.
So one of the key things that
Capacity Cache is used for
is to basically front a
database and to ensure
that the back-end store
is not impacted as much.
So what that means is that when
you deploy your Capacity Cache,
you want to split your key space
across a large number of nodes.
So that even if one
or two nodes fail,
the impact on the back-end
database is constrained,
and you don't really get
into the [INAUDIBLE] problem.
So this is where the
Memcache deployment can help,
because now you can spread
your data across a large number
of nodes and minimize the blast
radius if a node goes down.
So these are some of the
four different caching
patterns that we see.
So what I want to talk about
now is if your application use
case fits into one of
these caching patterns,
what are some of
the best practices
that you should be following
to ensure that you're running
the Memorystore instance
optimally for your application
workload?
So the first thing that
I would like you to do
is to understand and follow
the Memory Management Best
Practices for Redis.
One of the things that
Redis is notorious for
is poor memory management.
But as a managed
service, we do a lot
of things
behind-the-scenes to ensure
that we take care of some
of the inefficiencies,
in terms of memory management,
that happens in Redis for you.
But having said that, it
is super-important for you
to follow the best
practices, and especially
following-- monitoring
the right metrics
to ensure that your instance
is running optimally.
So let's take a look
at some of the metrics
that you should be monitoring.
So we have-- there
are four key metrics,
from our perspective, that
you should be monitoring
if you are using Memorystore,
when it comes to memory usage.
The first one is the
system memory usage ratio.
The system memory
usage ratio basically
tells you how much
system memory is
getting used in your instance.
So system memory
also includes memory
that is consumed by
memory fragmentation.
So if your instance
or your workload
is causing a lot of
memory fragmentation,
then the system
memory usage ratio
will tell you whether the
fragmentation is high or not.
So you absolutely should monitor
system memory usage ratio,
and ideally, set a
threshold of about 80%,
so that you can start making--
rightsizing your instances
once that threshold is hit.
The other one is
memory usage ratio.
That basically tells you
whether your deployed instance
is basically being
used optimally,
from a data usage perspective.
The next one is also
very interesting,
and something that we
introduced recently,
which is the time and
system memory overload.
So what happens
behind-the-scenes
is that we have
put a cap, in terms
of system memory, beyond which
we start blocking rights.
So when we do that,
the whole idea
is that we ensure that there is
enough system memory available,
and the system will not go into
an unstable state or crash.
But the experience
that you will get
when you hit that limit is,
essentially, "out of memory"
errors on your applications
when you try to do rights.
So one of the things
that you want to monitor
is that, is your instance
getting into that condition
or not?
Right?
It could be that there are
some peak workloads where
you briefly get
into that condition,
but then the steady
state is actually OK.
But it's something
to keep monitoring
which will allow
you to determine
whether you need to go
rightsize your instance or not.
And lastly, evictions is
a interesting-- good thing
to monitor, to ensure that if
you have an eviction policy set
where you expect the
keys to be evicted,
you want to monitor that.
You know, either
the [INAUDIBLE] set,
or the keys are getting
evicted so that the memory is
managed optimally.
So we highly recommend that
if you're using Memorystore,
you always monitor these
metrics and set thresholds,
or rather alerts, that will--
can proactively tell you
whether your instance is
getting into a bad state or not.
So once you've done the
memory usage best practices
and the monitoring around that,
the next thing you want to do
is, based on the
signals that you get,
you want to be able to
rightsize your instance.
So like I mentioned earlier,
your system memory usage ratio
is a very good indicator of how
well your system or instance is
performing, in terms
of memory consumption.
So if you go beyond 80%,
what you would want to do
is you want to rightsize your
instance by lowering the max
memory flag, which we
have provided as a G cloud
option, which will
allow you to give
more overhead for the instance.
This is super-important,
especially
when you are doing
things like backup,
or you are scaling
the instance often.
Because when you do a backup
or when you scale the instance,
we do kick-off an RDB process,
which essentially is a child
process that we spin up that
can consume, even double,
the memory that you
are using, depending
on the write rate
on your instance.
So especially if your instance
is a write-heavy instance,
we highly recommend that
you provide higher--
more overhead by
lowering max memory,
to ensure that operations
like backup and scaling
can happen successfully.
So that's about
rightsizing the instance.
So just to recap, monitor
your memory management
best practices, and rightsize
based on the thresholds
that you see for system
memory usage ratio,
or the metric around time
[INAUDIBLE] memory condition.
And finally, I just wanted to
touch upon some general best
practices that you should
be following, especially
for the primary store use case.
So one of the things
that I mentioned
earlier is that the
Memorystore instances
today, both basic and
standard tier instances,
are single-primary, meaning
all of your application queries
are going against
a single primary.
So what that means
is that you want
to be able to run your
benchmark for your application
and understand whether the
QPS, especially the QPS,
is hitting the limits.
The other thing I would
say is that if you have
a right-intensive workload,
meaning if it is--
80-20 reads.
What is this, 50-50 read-write?
You really want to
monitor your memory usage
and follow the best
practices that I mentioned
in the previous slide.
It is super-critical you
do that so that you can
keep your instance right size.
And not only that,
you can also determine
whether you're hitting the
limits of the Memorystore
instance.
One of the ways you can hit
the limits of the Memorystore
instance, and determine
whether you're
hitting the limits of
the Memorystore instance,
is by monitoring
the replication.
So if there's a lot of writes,
and if replication is not
keeping up, then what
can potentially happen
is that you are
getting fadeover.
You can lose some keys that
has not been replicated.
And you can basically
run into scenarios
where there's a lot
of key space loss
if the replication
log is too much.
So you basically
want to monitor it.
And lastly, if you're using
it as a primary store,
you absolutely should take
a backup of your instance.
We have published a paper on
how to scheduled backups using
Cloud Scheduler.
So that is published in
our solution website.
And we have also
published a solution paper
around best practices
around performance
from Memorystore,
Redis in general.
So I'd highly recommend if
you're using Memorystore today,
or thinking about using
Memorystore, that you follow
the best practices around memory
management, and you follow--
you monitor the metrics
that is recommended.
And also, learn
how to take actions
depending on what the
metrics are telling you.
So by doing that, you are
essentially being proactive
about ensuring that the
Memorystore instance runs
in a stable state.
And it also, more
importantly, allows
you to determine
whether the Memorystore
instance is actually
suitable for your workloads.
In some cases, if you find the
Memorystore instances are not
able to keep up,
then you will have
to shard your Memorystore
or application
workload across multiple
Memorystore instances
using blindside sharding.
So that, hopefully, gives
you a general understanding
on what are some of the
best practices that you
should be following
when using Memorystore.
And I hope that
you find it useful.
And it is something that you can
put into practice immediately.
So with that, I
just want to touch
upon some useful
links that will help
you understand a
lot more about what
I've just talked about here.
So if you-- there is
a Memory Management
Best Practices documentation
that we have published.
We have published the
Performance During Best
Practices, and we also have
published a solution paper
on how to scheduled backups
using Cloud Scheduler.
All this together,
hopefully, will give you
a great start, in terms of
running your Memorystore
instance optimally.
Thank you very much.